Musik Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser fantastischen neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO mit Stefan Tietze, Arm Apparello. Guten Tag. Hallo, fangen wir jetzt ohne Intro an oder was? Wir haben jetzt schon ein Intro gehört und dafür möchten wir uns natürlich auch sehr, sehr bedanken. Vielen, vielen Dank für dieses Intro an Roman und Lennart. Ja, vielen, vielen Dank, dass ihr immer so tolle Intros einsendet. Ist nicht so, dass ich heute vergessen hätte, das mitzunehmen hier heute in unser kleines Baumhaus, wo wir nur das haben, was wir mitgebracht haben, was wir die Leiter hochgeschleppt haben. Unsere Fantasie. Unsere Fantasie, ja genau, richtig. Und eine kleine Fanta haben wir mit dabei. Ja. Und den grossen Fanta haben wir auch dabei, Stefan. Hallo, ich bin der grosse Fanta, das hat man mich früher genannt, also ich habe mich früher in zwei Wochen lang so genannt, wegen Fun, Stefan, Fanta, da ist das Fun drin, das ist auch kein guter Spitzname, ehrlich gesagt. Dafür haben wir den Tini da, Florentini Villnorek, hallo, herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen fantastischen Folge. Ich bin hier knallhart in diese Folge geworfen worden. Das ist wie, ich fühle mich wie bei Rollercoaster-Tycoon, diese Leute, die man dann mit so einem Hebeding quasi nehmen konnte. Der ausziehen kann. Ja, wie man das kennt von so Kirmes, wo man dann so ein Kuscheltier ziehen kann. Dann nimmt man den kleinen Till hoch und setzt ihn dann irgendwo in der Achterbahn, weil man will, dass er diese Achterbahn austestet. Dann hat man vorher auch die Fusswege weggemacht, damit der nur noch da hängen kann. So fühle ich mich gerade. Und ich wurde in diese Folge geworfen. Ich mag aber auch, dass du den Yama-Slang beherrschst. Dass du sagst, ja, ich ziehe mir jetzt noch so eine kleine Kung-Fu-Panda-Action-Füge oder so. Habe ich letztens auch ein GIF gesehen von so einem Yama-Greifer, so Plüschtieren und dann greift einer dann irgendwie so
den Pikachu oder was und dann
kommt aus den Tieren
so eine Tatze raus
und packt den und zieht den runter.
Normal einfach eine Katze in diesen ganzen
Plüschtieren drin, die da geschlafen hat und die einfach
dem wieder weggenommen hat. Und in dem Gif
sieht man nur von hinten diese
Was-Hände, die meine Lieblingshände
sind. Einfach die
Zusammengekniffen und Augenbrauen und dann diese weitoffenen Hände. Was? Ja, aber auch nicht schlecht. Das heißt, man hätte auch theoretisch eine Katze ziehen können. Das stimmt natürlich. Du hättest dir eine Katze ziehen können, auch wenn die Katze dir dann eine zieht. Das musst du halt dann überlegen, ob das das wert ist. Ey, das ist ein Ziehen und Ziehen. Wirklich. Das ganze Leben ist ein Ziehen. Findest du nicht auch? Ja. Ich war gestern, erst mal vielen, vielen lieben Dank an alle, die in Köln bei unserer Show waren. Ah, ich habe mich schon die ganze Woche gefreut. Ach, als ich das gesehen habe auf der Bühne, ihr habt es ja vielleicht mitbekommen auf der Bühne, wir haben Tickets verlost zu Simple Minds. Stefan, die Augen gingen auf, als der Veranstalter gesagt hat, ja, Simple Minds spielt gegenüber am Sonntag und Stefan, die Augen gehen auf und wow, meine Jungen. Die Situation war ja die, beim Soundcheck habe ich glaube ich irgendwann angefangen, Don't You zu singen. Don't You, forget about me, I'll be alone. So, und da habe ich es gesungen, fantastisch, engelsgleich, und von hinten kam ein Mann in diesem komplett leeren Soundcheck-Gebrabbel, kam der von hinten angelaufen, der uns vorher auch begrüsst hat und so. Der hat sich einfach einen Weg durch diese Stuhl reingebahnt und hat gerufen, und hat nur so ein Poster in der Hand gehalten, so ein Veranstaltungsposter, und hat gesagt, das ist Simple Mainz, die spielen am Sonntag hier in Köln gegenüber im Palladium. Deswegen haben wir letzte Woche dann Tickets verlosen dürfen, weil er uns netterweise ein paar Tickets zur Verfügung gestellt hat.
Nicht nur Tickets haben wir verlost, nein, auch die Möglichkeit, einen herrlichen romantischen Abend zusammen mit Stefan Tietze zu verbringen.
Denn nicht nur durften die Glücklichen aus dem Publikum dieses tolle Konzert sehen, sondern sie durften es auch mit einer einmaligen Begleitung sehen.
Und ich habe mich die ganze Woche darauf gefreut, jetzt in dem Moment mitzubekommen, wie das passiert ist, worüber habt ihr geredet, wie war die Stimmung, war ihr danach noch was trinken? Es war tatsächlich ein bisschen anders. Du hast den ganzen Tag einen Abend mit mir verlost, was wir primär verlost haben, waren Tickets für die Simple Minds. Nee, es gab schon auch einfach Meet and Greet mit dir und dass man zusammen Arm in Arm, ich mag es ja so, einen Abend schweißt ja auch zusammen, man kommt an, man fremd ein bisschen, ah hallo, ja, ich höre den Podcast, aha, okay, aber dann spätestens bei der dritten Wiederholung von Don't you, hängt man sich in den Armen und ist mit dabei und man schüttet Bier über den anderen, oh sorry und egal und dann ist man am Ende richtig bestbody, es geht noch was trinken und dann, ah, entsteht so eine tolle Freundschaft daraus. Ja, mir gefällt dieses fiesante Grinsen nicht, was du da hast, denn ich hatte einen grossartigen Abend. Es war ein bisschen anders, muss man sich vorstellen, man hat sich da nicht so gut gefunden. Heißt, ich war dann mit meiner Begleitung da, ich hatte nämlich zwei, ein Plus eins noch und die beiden Fans sind hin und dann haben wir geschrieben, ich wollte auch sicher gehen, dass die natürlich auch reinkommen, wir waren in Kontakt und so und dann drin hat man sich einfach komplett verloren, da konnte man sich auch leider nicht treffen. Ich habe dann beide aber tatsächlich noch getroffen und wir haben uns noch lustig unterhalten und es war sehr schön. Ach, das ist doch toll. Denn die Hanna, die dritte Person, es war ja mit das verwirrendste Gewinnspiel, was es jemals in der Welt der Gewinnspiele gab. Denn wir hatten zwei Tickets, wollten aber so nur tun, als hätten wir eins. An unserer Stelle Meas Kulpas, weil wir haben das ein bisschen verkackt, dramaturgischer Effekt blieb aus, hinten der Shock Value blieb aus.
Wir haben erwartet, dass das Publikum tobt,
in dem Moment, in dem wir sagen, ja, du bist ausgeschieden, du kriegst
keine Leinticket,
und dann das Publikum rastet aus,
aber nein, es war wesentlich verwirrender.
Es war irgendwann Verwirrung, was aber auch
dazu beitragt zu dieser großen Verwirrung war,
dass wir zwei Leute auf die Bühne
holen wollten für dieses Quiz, was wir uns
aus der Lameng ausgedacht haben, es kam aber noch die Hanna auf die Bühne gelaufen einfach, die ihn auch am Ende gewonnen hat. Die eigentlich der Held ist der ganzen Geschichte, die für ihre Freundin. Oder Antagonistin. Ja, die einfach gesagt hat, egal ob ich aufgerufen werde oder nicht, ich gehe da jetzt hin und hole einfach ein Ticket oder einen Gästelissenplatz für meine Freundin, Freund. Freund. So, und dann war der Freund da. Was ich aber nicht mitbekommen hatte, dass sie es für die Begleitung gemacht hat, habe ich gar nicht so richtig mitbekommen. Ich dachte dann, ich habe die ganze Zeit sie erwartet, musste dann aber Janik auf die Gästelese schreiben. Das heißt, Janik war dann da. Ah, schön. Netter Kerl, großer Simple Minds Fan, es wäre das beste Konzert gewesen, er ist der große Fan gewesen, hat sich aber nicht getraut, da auf die Bühne zu kommen am Dienstag letzte Woche. Ach, das ist doch schön, dass Hanna da für ihn ins Feuer sprungen. Hanna ist ins Feuer gesprungen und hat,
obwohl sie noch weniger Ahnung hat,
als ich, Simple-Main-Stickets gewonnen.
Janik war da, hatte einen tollen Abend,
ich hatte da einen tollen Abend
und die Finja habe ich auch noch getroffen.
Und die ja lustigerweise da war,
weil sie auch gewonnen hat,
aber ihr Vater war auch da,
hat auch Stickets, weil sie kam extra aus Bielefeld nach Köln und was eine große Fügung des Schicksals, ein großer Zufall, ihr Vater hatte eh auch Tickets für diese Show in Köln, für die Simple Minds.
Deswegen konnte sie einfach ihren Vater, der alleine hingegangen wäre sonst, begleiten.
Also merkwürdig, Hochtausend.
Ich kenne jetzt deren Beziehung nicht, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine gute Dynamik ist, wenn du sagst, jetzt gehe ich mal endlich alleine, schön, ich Simple Minds damals und dann sagt die Tochter, du, ja, willst du auch Tickets gewonnen? Gibt's auch ein Ticket? Ach, schön, dann gehen wir zusammen hin. Und sie hat mir noch erzählt, dass sie jetzt ein großes Konzertjahr hat, Five Seconds of Summer, One Direction, Harry Styles, alle von One Direction und diese ganzen, also man kriegt eine gute Idee, was ihr Musikgeschmack ist.
Und dann auch Simple Minds. Und dann hat sich überlegt, sie bedeutet ihren Vater zu Simple Minds. Simple Minds rundet jeden Musikgeschmack ab. Du kannst einfach immer unten noch Simple Minds hinschreiben und das ist eine gute Abrundung. Ja, es ist so der typische, also hier im NRW würde man sagen WDR2-Song. Dieser typische Lokalradio, ja, alle hören, alle hören das und alle kennen das auch, diesen einen Song. Ich bin ja, was Musikgeschlag angreift, komplett ruiniert worden von dem Spotify-Jahresrückblick, wo du immer sehen kannst, welche Interpreten du am meisten gehört hast. Und mittlerweile ist es bei mir schon so drin, ich denke jetzt schon hin auf den nächsten Jahresrückblick. Und oft ist es so, manchmal spielt man irgendwie ein Videospiel oder so und hört halt irgendwie drei Stunden lang eine Playlist, dann macht man sich was zu essen. Und ich habe jetzt zwei Rechner und der eine Rechner läuft dann einfach noch entweder die ganze Nacht oder stundenlang durch und man denkt sich, fuck, das wird so stark meinen Jahresrückblick beeinflussen. Ich muss ab jetzt wieder versuchen, in die andere Richtung zu lenken, muss jetzt wieder explizit andere Musik hören, damit nicht diese eine Nacht mein ganzes Jahr ruiniert. Und irgendwann hörst du Musik gar nicht mehr, weil du sie hören willst, sondern nur noch, weil du versuchen willst, sein Image vor Doktor Spotify wieder aufzupolieren. Mein Sweetspot sind halt immer nur diese paar Wochen nach Jahresrückblick, wo das Jahr aber noch läuft. Das heißt, das, was man erst ab dem 1. ersten ersten ist erst wieder gefährlich für den algorithmus da darf man endlich frei sein das sind zwei wochen wo ich höre was ich will wo man wirklich nicht mehr genießen kann da genieße ich da lege ich mich zurück und habe die beste zeit da seht ihr mich dann so mit augen zu und kopfhörern auf durch mein wohnzimmer tanzen ja das sind meine zeit der rest ist nur angestrengte ich muss das jetzt hören jastellen, ich muss an diesen Twitter-Post denken, ich darf jetzt nicht schon wieder Katie Melua rauf und runter hören, die will ich gerade auf die sechs drücken, weil die sechs wird nicht mehr angezeigt, Katie Melua muss runter auf die sechs und Nelly Furtado kann ich vielleicht was versuchen, um zu holen. Ich will aber nicht auf meinen Katie Melua-Konsum verzichten, das heißt, ich muss andere mehr hören. Irgendwann machst du die Exit-Tabelle auf und sagst, okay, wie viele Stunden habe ich noch diese Woche? Wie viele Plays habe ich noch frei für Katie? Und wie viel muss ich dann doch noch irgendwie in Franz Liszt stecken, damit der möglichst oben ist, weil der ist irgendwie fernzieht. Ja, das ist mein Problem, Franz Liszt ist bei mir zu weit oben und deswegen, also die Franz Liszt dieser Welt sind zu weit oben und deswegen, ich hatte noch nie einen coolen Jahresrückblick, den ich posten konnte. Ja, unangenehm. Ich mag auch, also dann ist immer Rock und Oper irgendwie oben und man denkt so, Jesus Christ, das ist so wirklich gewollt. Es ist so, ich hasse mich dafür selbst. Es ist wirklich so, mit diesem Typen, wenn ich das nicht wissen würde, dass ich es bin und diesen Jahresrückblick ankomme, würde ich sagen, oh mein Gott, pretentious fucker. Wenn ich den auf der. Wenn ich den auf einer Party sehen würde, würde ich da nicht reden. Würdest du dich selbst matchen, wenn du so nur die Serien, die der andere sieht, nur die Lieder hört, nur die Filme, die er mag, würdest du dich selbst matchen? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Zwangsäufig ja, glaube ich doch, weil gleiche Interessen natürlich auch irgendwie ein gleiches Weltbild und so. Ja, aber Interessen ist ja ein Unterschied zwischen Interesse und was du tatsächlich machst. Ja, genau. Ja, du interessierst dich für Wagner und James A. A. Kester. James A. Kester. Aber was du tatsächlich hörst, ist irgendwie U2 und Mario Barth. So, und dann, das wird dann oben angezeigt. Ich finde das so, ich finde, das ist immer so pretentious, mein fucking Musikgeschmeid. Naja, und ich weiß nicht, ob das so geht, auch bei den Playlists, unten hast du dann das Spotify-Radio. Also sozusagen, wenn die Playlist ausläuft, hast du unten so eine Autovervollständigung. Spotify schlägt dir Songs vor, also basierend auf dieser Playlist passen auch noch folgende Vorschläge. Und dann läuft unten einfach die Playlist weiter. Und bei mir ist es, weil meine Playlists so durcheinander sind, mit verschiedenen Genres durcheinander gemixt, und das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn. Und es ist wirklich eine bunte Mischung aus grobem Unfug. Songs, die ich aus Werbung gesehen habe, Songs, keine Ahnung, die mich gut fühlen lassen, aber das ist einfach eine große, doofe Mischung. Und Spotify ist immer massiv überfordert, was da drunter anzeigen soll. Das ist eigentlich ein grosser 404-Error. Aber funktioniert das eigentlich auch für Podcasts? Schaffen wir es als das Podcast-Ufo-Podcast-Projekt, dass unser Podcast immer in der Autovervollständigung jeder Playlist mit drin ist, so dass egal was Leute hören, immer wenn die Playlist zu Ende ist, kommt sofort irgendwie ein Podcast von uns einfach als Werbemittel. Einfach damit wir die Kratzeis-Folge einfach immer drunter. Versucht mal ihr zu Hause keine Ahnung, ihr hört den neuen Song von Bruno Mars und im Anschluss sofort Kratzeis, sodass der Algorithmus denkt, ah, das passt gut zusammen. Alle, die Bruno Mars hören, kriegen danach auch Kratzeis. Versucht mal den zu trainieren, damit wir einfach in jede Playlist reinsneaken. Egal, worum es geht, kommen immer wir dann dazu. Und zu den Kaffeemaschinen-Sound oder irgendwie sowas. Bei mir hatte ich, ich habe immer das Gefühl, man liest meine Songs des Jahres und denkt, okay, du hattest einfach Hunger. So, jeder Song hat was mit Essen zu tun. Hunger Games-Soundtrack. Auf Nummer eins, Hunger Games. Plain Plate of Noodles ist auf Platz Nummer eins. Tequila auf Platz zwei. Pina Colada. Put the lime in the coconut. Einfach alles hat mit Essen zu tun, wo ich mir auch denke, ja, es kann sein, dass du am Ende deines Lebens merkst, du magst einfach Musik, wo es um Essen geht. Ist egal, wie es musikalisch aussieht, du magst einfach, wenn du um Essen gesungen wirst. Das finde ich interessant. Pizza Hut Song, Hot Dog, der Hot Dog Song. Überall Werbesongs aus berühmten Esswerbungen, der Zottsahne-Joghurt-Song. Überall halt Werbesongs aus berühmten S-Werbungen. Der Zott-Sahne-Joghurt-Song. Mit auf dem Jahresrückblick einfach schön. Hinein ins Wiggin-Feeling. Ja, genau so was. Hinein ins, das ist auf Nummer eins. Die Mini-Winni-Würstchen-Kette. Schön, der Dalmeier-Song. Ja, die Pommersche. Ja, wird sich stark, wird sich gut. Da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da Das sind Stefan und Florentine, Maika Land. Irgendwie sowas ging der doch. Ich bin mir nicht mehr hundertprozentig sicher. Aber das, wenn ich nicht lenk, wenn das die Songs sind. Und jetzt ohne Scheiss, ich möchte, dass alle Leute, die ihre Spotify-Jahresrückblicke posten, die nicht mehr posten, sondern nur noch die, die aus irgendwelchen Gründen ihre Sachen nicht gepostet haben. Ich fände da liegen ja die spannenden Geschichten.ichten. Ich fände einen Twitter-Account gut, an den man anonym seinen Jahresrückblick schicken kann. Und der postet die, der Club der anonymen Spotify-Playlist. Wir machen den Twitter-Account auf, einfach so die anonymen Spotify-Playlisten-Poster. Ich meine, im Mai. Es ist so seltsam, dass wir jetzt darüber reden, weil es ist wirklich nur zwei Wochen spannend. Solche Sachen müssen vorbereitet sein. Da brauchen wir ein Logo, da brauchen wir einen Banner, einen Header. Und falls ihr euren Jahresrückblick seht. Banner und Header? Leute, macht euch bereit. Auf Mobile und Desktop, alles. Profilbeek und ein Avatar brauchen wir auch noch. Wir brauchen Futter und Impressum, wir brauchen alles. Und falls ihr euch denkt, dann seht ihr euren Jahresrückblick und denkt euch, den werden wir sicherlich nicht posten, dann schickt ihn uns. Da sind doch die spannenden Geschichten. Manchmal denke ich mir, es ist doch viel spannender, was Leute nicht im Internet teilen. Ich meine, klar, man sieht coole Sachen und so und das Internet ist irgendwie ein Ort von allem, Internet of Things, bla bla bla bla bla. Da ist immer alles, da ist jetzt Fokus drauf. Aber es ist doch viel spannender, was die Leute eben nicht bereit sind, mit der Öffentlichkeit zu teilen. Und da müsste es doch eigentlich so ein anonymes Spiel, wie so einen Kindertisch im Internet geben. Ja, so ein Gegenstück, der immer das postet, was du nicht postest. Genau, wo man auch Tweets hinschicken kann. Vielleicht machen wir es noch größer. Es ist ein Twitter-Account, wo Leute Sachen hinschicken, gegen die sie sich entschieden haben, das zu posten. Die anonymen Poster, wo du Dinge posten kannst, aber du willst nicht, dass es unter deinem Namen erscheint, sondern einfach so ein Sammelbecken für alle peinlichen Sachen des Internets. Die man niemals posten würde unter seinem Namen. Die man selber so Ideen, so eine Poetry Slam-Idee, die man hatte und dann verworfen hat. Wir posten euren peinlichen Kram und anonym. Wir sammeln nicht PKA, peinlicher Kram anonym. Ja. Finde ich super, das lass uns richtig gut. Ich meine, wir brauchen Monate, bis wir das überhaupt durchkriegen. Im Dezember sind wir startklar. Ja, mal gucken, Dezember, welches Jahr? Naja, und dann war ich jedenfalls da und hab die Sündin Mainz geschaut und so. Ich hab mich vorher ein bisschen eingelesen. Tolle, tolle Band, tolle Historie.
Wie heißen die Teilnehmer?
Frag mich nichts.
Bitte frag.
Wie heißt der Schlagzeuger?
Greg.
Gregory, kurz für Gregory.
Clint, Clintors.
Krass, ist ja richtig gut vorbereitet.
Simple Minds.
Und ich kannte ja zwei Songs, zwei tolle Songs, Don't You und ...
Don't You, Alive and Kicking, kennen auch viele, auch ein Megasong. Und diese beiden Songs, ich dachte mir die ganze Zeit, weil die spielen jetzt wahrscheinlich eineinhalb Stunden. Wann platzieren die diese Songs? Ja, und mir war relativ klar, dass Don't You's The Song ist, Alive and Kicking der vorletzte Song,
und davor spielen sie Random Shit, weil
niemand kennt den Rest. Red Hot Chili Peppers.
Also es gibt noch Belfast Child und so ein paar andere Songs, die man noch
kennt und so, aber man hat gemerkt,
die haben, und es waren ja da wahrscheinlich die
Hardcore Simple Minds Fans, weil
wer sonst geht zu diesen Konzerten, ausser die und
Leute, die random Guestlistenplätze gewinnen.
Und selbst die konnten nur so vier
Songs auswendig, inklusive
Don't You and Alive
Vielen Dank. Sonst geht's so diesen Konzerten, ausser die und Leute, die random Guestlistenplätze gewinnen. Und selbst die konnten nur so vier Songs auswendig, inklusive Don't You and Alive and Kicking. Und dann haben die wirklich, es gab eine Pause zwischendurch, das ist schon ein bisschen eine ältere Band, die wollten eine Pause machen. Und dann davor Belfast Child, das kennt man alle. Ich meine, das ist die alte Bitburger Werbung. Kennst du das noch? Kennst du bestimmt, diese ganz berühmte Melodie. Und daher ist das Lied. Und das haben die, eines der bekanntesten, das haben die vor der Pause gespielt, als Höhepunkt vor der Pause. Und dann relativ schnell in einem zweiten Teil kam dann aber in der Mitte John Don't You. Aber wirklich, aber das steht schon auf.
Zwölf Minuten lang wurde dieser Song gestretched,
weil da gibt es da hinten dieses La la la la, la la la la,
diesen La la la Mitsing-Teil.
Und der wurde wirklich so lange gestretched,
wie das möglich ist, überhaupt menschenmöglich.
Und ja, da hatten wir alle eine gute Zeit.
Und dann ganz am Ende, letzter Song war dann Alive and Kicking.
Also sehr, sehr gut gelöst. Also die Lücken, generell tolle Band, Schlagzeugerinnen inzwischen am Start. Also ein paar Beat-Band-Mitglieder wurden inzwischen ausgetauscht wegen Alt. Aber sehr gut. Also tolle Band, tolle Akustik, war fantastisch. Was heißt Alt, weil die Knochen haben sich aufgelöst oder wie? Und dir war dann nur noch Haut oder was? Ja. Und die waren dann nur noch, lagen in so einem Eimer einfach drin, ohne Knochen. Unkonserviert. Und der konnte dann nicht mit dem Schlagzeug spielen, weil er hatte keine Knochen mehr. Man hat versucht, dann dieses Einmachglas mit dem Kopf und diesen vielen Kabeln und den Witzen, die da durchschießen, da hinzustellen. Und der Körper hängt dann unten einfach wie so ein Lappen raus. Hängt da wie ein Lappen raus, lange Zeit. Für mehrere Touren, unbeliebte Simple Minds Tour. Und dann hat man aber irgendwann gesagt, okay, die spielen nicht mehr, hängen aber einfach trotzdem mit auf der Bühne. Und die auch so, wir heißen Simple Minds, nicht Simple Bodies. Okay, verstehe, nicht Schlaff Bodies. Nicht Schlaff Bodies. Nicht Soft Bodies. Ja, das sind nicht wir, das sind nicht wir. Ja, und dann, also ein guter Auftritt, ich hatte einen mega Abend mit der Einschränkung, dass mir wieder aufgefallen ist, warum ich zwei Jahre jetzt nicht auf Konzerten war.
Covid.
Und weil ich sehr gross bin. Ja. Ich bin so gross, dass wenn ich dann ein Getränk hole oder eine Pause draußen war und dann wieder zurückkomme, es war nur ein grosser Stehplatzraum und gehe dann da rein wieder, um mich da hinzustellen, um diese Band anzugucken. Alle hassen mich. Es gibt niemanden, ich habe deswegen in meinem Leben ungelernt, so viel Hass entgegenzutreten. Aber in dem Moment, wo man sich durch den Weg durch die Masse bahnt, hinter einem alle geben einem Sprüche. Und bleib jetzt nicht hier stehen, bleib jetzt nicht hier stehen, nee, geh bitte weiter und so. Das sind Sprüche? Naja, fiese Mundäusserungen. Wow, die Leute sagen, bleib jetzt hier nicht stehen? Bleib bitte nicht stehen. Nee, komm, das geht nicht und sowas. Dann wurde ich auf Holländisch angesprochen, weil da waren Holländer und er hat mir auf Holländisch zugeprabbelt und meinte, ich darf jetzt, und ich habe aber auch das verstanden und habe auf Deutsch geantwortet und wir haben so einen bilingualen, passiv-aggressiven Streit ausgetragen. Ich glaube, im Streit versteht man jede Sprache der Welt. Wenn du wütend bist, kannst du jeden verstehen. Aber es gab doch auch kulturelle Schwierigkeiten, weil ich habe lange Zeit gedacht, er macht Scherze und bin dann stehen geblieben, bis er dann in der, ja, ich sage mal, ein paar Dezibel draufgelegt hat in seiner Stimme und hat dann gemerkt, oh, das ist dem ganz so gar nicht unwichtig. Es ist ja aus seiner Perspektive das Dümmste, was er machen kann, dich anzusprechen, damit du stehen bleibst. Besser wäre es ja, wenn du einfach in ihm vorbeiläufst. Ja, genau, aber immer wenn ich Andeutung gemacht habe, dass das jetzt mein Platz ist für den Rest des anderthalb Stunden des Konzerts. Das ist unangenehm. Ja, und dann immer, man fühlt sich nie, ich habe mich nie wohl gefühlt da, weil irgendwann, dann habe ich einen anderen großen Mann gesehen und so, der hat auch eine große Frau und dann habe ich mich mit meiner Breitung halt daneben gestellt, weil ich dachte so, hier ist ja eh schon verloren, also die Leute dahinter ist eh schon Brachland. Ja. Dann kann ich mich ja da jetzt hinstellen und da waren dann aber auch diese Holländer, die mich dann angesprochen haben von der Seite fies. Die dann auch genug hatten, wenn der dritte Grosse dazukommt. Genau, aber dann hat der andere grosse Mann mich dann so ein bisschen gelehrt. Der war sehr gut darin, mir zu erklären, dass man kein Schlesgewissen haben muss. Ja, aber wenn du dich so ganz breitbeinig hinstellst, sodass du von der Kopfhöhe wieder auf normalem Niveau bist? Ja, ich habe auch den Ausfallschritt gemacht. Ich habe das eine Bein ein bisschen nach vorne
und dann habe ich mich so leicht angelehnt,
nach unten und war ein bisschen kleiner.
Und dann, als das Konzert angefangen hat, das Licht wieder auszugangen ist,
habe ich mich zack wieder hoch hingestellt
und hinter mir so ein Mwaaa.
Ja.
Super unangenehm, weil ich meine,
es ist ja so, im Kino
rede ich ja auch nicht, um mal ein altes Beispiel von uns zu nehmen, weil ich ja auch nicht, ich kann das nicht ertragen, also nicht nur will ich die anderen nicht stören, habe ich eh schon keinen Bock drauf, aber ich könnte es auch gar nicht, weil ich ein schlechtes Gewissen hätte und würde mich doof fühlen. Ich will nicht, dass Leute um mich herum mich hassen, auch wenn es fremde Menschen sind. Aber in dem Moment, wo es darum geht, ein Konzert zu besuchen, man will sich ja nicht, weil man gross ist, in die letzte Reihe stellen.
Zumal man ja auch mit Leuten dann da ist. fremde Menschen sind. Aber in dem Moment, wo es auch umgegeht, ein Konzert zu besuchen, man will sich ja nicht,
wenn man groß ist, in die letzte Reihe stellen.
Zumal man ja auch mit Leuten dann da ist,
die ja auch sehen wollen.
Und dann hat mir der Mann
den cleveren Satz gesagt,
er hat sehr clevere Sachen gesagt,
er war wie so eine Obi-Wan-Figur,
der Mann. Und du denkst,
ich bin der Böse, wie ich gerade, er ist der Protagonist,
er hat die guten Zeilen bekommen, ich bin der Böse. Ich dachte, ich bin Luke Skywalker, der weinerliche Luke Skywalker von Tatooine und er ist Obi-Wan, der mir vor Ort noch mal sagt, wo es hingeht und dann war ich am Ende ein anderer Mann. Ich bin als Junge rein und als Mann wieder raus. Okay, sehr gut. Ja, war auch sehr eng da. So, und dann bin ich dahin und er hat mir gesagt, nee, zum einen, deine Begleitung soll ja auch sehen können, das heißt, warum sollst du dich nach hinten hinstellen, weil sie ist nicht so groß wie du. War schon super, super Erklärung Nummer eins. Dann hat er gesagt, grob besser Tipp, dreh dich einfach nicht mehr um und frag, ob es jetzt passt, sondern stell dich einfach hin und schau stur nach vorne. Das war auch ein Arschloch, ob ich war, ehrlich gesagt. Ich finde es geil, dass ihr sofort auf so einer Ebene zusammen seid. Auf einer literal Ebene. Sich wirklich Lebensweisheiten austauscht und einfach sagt so, ja, der hat wahrscheinlich auch in dir sich selbst gesehen, wie er früher war. Er sah auch ein bisschen aus wie ich in 30 Jahren oder so. Es war toll zu sehen. Der war richtig cool, war noch auf einer Wellenlänge. Aber warum hat er nicht den Tipp gegeben, hol dir eine Begleitung, die auch so gross ist, was er anscheinend gemacht hat. Er hat es gemacht, ja. Er hat eine sehr, sehr grosse Frau und war mit ihr dann da. Wahrscheinlich haben die sich so kennengelernt, wenn sie sich immer hinten sammeln, dass es dann direkt so wird, dann aussortiert und dann kann man sich direkt kennenlernen. Aber ich fand es eine spannende Frage, darf man
als grosser Mensch im Konzert
sich auch einfach dahin stellen, wo alle stehen wollen,
nämlich grob in der Mitte?
Oder hat man dann wirklich die Pflicht,
sich größenmäßig zu sortieren und man
stellt sich ganz nach hinten, weil dann müsste ich bei jedem
Konzert ganz hinten stehen. Und da kann ich für mich
nicht Don't you genießen. Es ist die klassische
Dynamik, du stehst, wo du stehst und alle
hinter dir versuchen, sich wegzubewegen,
sodass sie noch was sehen können und die,
die danach kommen, sind dann unzufrieden und immer
Vielen Dank. Ich will mich nicht Downschuh genießen. Es ist die klassische Dynamik, du stehst, wo du stehst und alle hinter dir versuchen, sich wegzubewegen, sodass sie noch was sehen können. Und die, die danach kommen, sind dann unzufrieden. Und immer wenn du dich bewegst, kann man so aus der Vogelperspektive sehen, wie du so wellenartige Bewegungen hinter dir herziehst, wo dann alle die Leute sind, die dann vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Platz für sich wollen. Also bist du ja so ein bisschen der Fels in der Brandung, der hinter dir eine Möglichkeit aufmacht, dass Leute da sind, die vielleicht gar nicht sie sehen wollen oder die einfach ein bisschen ihre Ruhe haben wollen, weil da vielleicht weniger Leute stehen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von Konzerten, ich war in zwei Konzerten meines Lebens und wusste bei beiden überhaupt gar nicht, was ich machen soll, was genau ich jetzt geniessen soll, was genau jetzt, wo ich jubeln soll, welche Emotion wann angebracht ist, bin ich traurig, wenn es zu Ende ist, freue ich mich, wenn es zu Ende ist. Ich wusste nicht, wo er mit meinen Emotionen ist, deswegen habe ich es gelassen und war seitdem auch nicht mehr auf einem Konzert. Warum hast du dir da nicht zugetraut, einfach mal deine Gefühle zuzulassen, sondern warum hattest du das Gefühl, du musst hier einer gewissen Norm enden? Naja, weil normalerweise mache ich gar nichts, wenn ich Musik höre. Also ich kann Ihnen das mal so zeigen und ich Musik höre, dann sitze ich hier so und mein Gesichtsausdruck ist dieser hier. Was fühlen Sie dabei, wenn Sie diese Musik hören? Nichts, überhaupt nichts. Lehre, innere Lehre. Und dann haben Sie sich gedacht, diese Lehre möchte ich live erleben. Dann habe ich gesagt, das will ich auch mal mit anderen Leuten erleben.
Und dann bist du da und du merkst, alle anderen reagieren anders.
Die alle, die reissen ihre Münder auf, die Augen wackeln mit den Ohren, die Haare wehen von links nach rechts.
Das finde ich, finde ich bei Konzert.
So viel passiert da bei denen im Gesicht.
Und dann habe ich mir überlegt, mache ich es falsch, genieße ich Musik falsch, soll ich auch mehr wackeln und zappeln? Und ich habe für mich entschieden, nein, ich gehe nur noch ein Konzert, wo man sich hinsetzen kann. Ah ja, Seated Concerts. Genau. Sagt man auf Englisch. Genau. Und dann setze ich mich da hin und mache nichts. Und da geben die Leute in der Regel auch Ruhe. Ich weiß nicht, wie du es mitbekommen hast, aber eine Welle geht durch Deutschland. Eine Welle geht durch Deutschland und es ist mir nicht, ich bin mir nicht zu schade zu sagen, dass ich sie ausgelöst habe, denn ich habe eine Petition gestartet. Eine Petition gestartet für das härtere Durchgreifen des deutschen Bahnpersonals im Ruhebereich.
Und ich bin stolz darauf, dass mittlerweile schon 1600 Leute diese Petition unterzeichnet haben. Endlich muss sich was tun. Endlich muss sich was tun. Die Welt kann eine bessere werden mit kleineren, kleineren Schritten. Denn der Ruhebereich existiert, das deutsche Bahnpersonal ist bereits da, aber aus irgendeinem Grund setzen die den nicht durch. Deswegen soll Petition soll das einfach erzwingen. Kurze Petitionskritik. Ich habe es gelesen und ich weiss ja, du brennst dafür. Wir haben im Podcast auch schon oft darüber gesprochen, der Ruhe bereit und ich bin da komplett aus deiner Seite, muss härter durchgesetzt werden. Nur dann macht er Sinn und macht Spaß und das Bahnfahren zu einem schürenen Erlebnis. Und mir gefiel es sehr schön, wie du es ausgedrückt hast. Denn es ist ja wirklich so, dass man ja schon sehr viel mag und sehr viel richtig ist und es ja gar nicht viel erfordert. Alle Puzzlestücke, die man braucht für das fertige Bild, sind ja schon da. Es erfordert ja nur einfach mal hier und da ein und dann können sie ja noch so eine Schokolade dahinter hergeben oder sowas. Man will ja selber nicht der Bad Cop sein und das macht es ja zu einem schlechteren Ergebnis dann. Und es haben noch zu wenig unterschrieben, deswegen jetzt hier auch noch mal. Schaut auf change.org vorbei. Härtere Durchsetzung des Ruhebereichs vom DB-Personal. Sucht gerne nach Ruhebereich auf change.org. Ja, da klingt euch durch die ganz vielen sinnvollen Petitionen. Ja, da klingt die alle weg, löscht die alle, beschwert euch, damit die weg sind, damit meine Höhe nach oben geht. Und dann könnt ihr unterschreiben, weil ich glaube, ab einem gewissen Punkt muss ja die Bahn reagieren. Die Bahn ist ja, sag ich mal, Marketing bewusst. Das ist ja nicht wie die Politik, wo man sagt, hört auf mit irgendwas, das ist ja egal. Aber bei der Bahn, wenn genug Leute das wollen, dann ist das ja auch ein wirklicher Anreiz, für die das zu tun. Ich fand es auch interessant, dass dann da stand, ab 1500, nächster Milestone, und dann stand drunter, und offenbar haben die da so ein paar Anhaltspunkte, um das zu belegen, ab 1500 wird es von lokalen Medien aufgegriffen. Das hat mir gefallen, weil ich dachte, da will man doch nur hin. Da will ich hin. Man will doch in den Regensburger Stadtanzeiger oder sowas, aber noch kleiner Bus, die Brunsbacher Morgenpost oder sowas. Die Rhein-Neckar-Zeitung, da muss es stehen. Da will man hin, da will man sein und da kriegst du auch den Platz, den du verdienst. Wenn du dann bei der Zeit oder so aufgegriffen wirst, da kriegst du dann so ein paar Zeilchen da. Aber nein, nein, nein, du verdienst ja das Grosse. Ich will ja auch Fotoshootings, ich will ja dich im ICE sehen, mit dem Finger vor den Mund, so ein gestelltes Bild und dann noch so ein seliges Bild.
Ich frage mich, wie weit das gehen kann. Spiegelcover, Sternencover, irgendwie sowas in Richtung Times Cover, alles ist machbar, alles ist machbar, The Man Who Brought Back Silence. Einfach so will ich einfach in die Geschichte eingehen.
Ich find geil, wenn so iconic bei Timings kann man so ein Cover gibt, wo du dann einfach nur den und es es ist nur schwarz-weiss, und man sieht nur den Finger vor deinen Lippen, deine lockigen Haare, Barts braucht man nur, und dann deinen Finger vor den Lippen, und weiss ah, the guy from Germany who brought silence back.
Who made silence sexy again.
Yeah, who made this loud times sexy again.
Ja, ich bin gespannt, wie weit das gehen kann, aber auch toll zu sehen, welchen Gegenwind man bekommt, weil so eine Petition, die verlässt ja ab einem gewissen Punkt die eigene Blase. Und das ist ja bei uns so, wir verlassen ja selten unsere eigene Blase. Wenn wir da posten mit Podcasts und bla und uns eigenen, dann sind das immer dieselben Leute, mehr oder weniger. Aber sobald so eine Petition auch mal irgendwie von Leuten retweetet wird, die dann so leicht die Blase überlappen, dann kriegt man dann auch Leute, die sagen so, ja, gibt es keine anderen Probleme, stell dich nicht so an, wo wirklich dann auch Gegenwind kommt, was ich auch ganz spannend fand, dass wirklich auch Leute dagegen sind, wo man sich immer denkt, so ich habe eine Meinung, wo ich mir denke, das ist doch offensichtlich, das ist doch eine gute Lösung, aber es gibt Leute, die sagen, sie sind dagegen, mit Kinder sollen laut sein dürfen, sonst werden die schlechte Erwachsene. Das ist nicht der Punkt. Ganz interessante Thesen. Spannend, aber auch nicht der Punkt. Also für die gibt es ja Familienbereich. Überhaupt nicht der Punkt, ist nicht der Punkt. Aber ganz, ganz tolle Sachen auf jeden Fall. Und dann auch so Leute, die kommen mit so, ja, wie wäre es denn mal wieder, vielleicht selber mit Leuten zu kommunizieren, muss ja nicht alles über die Behörden machen und so, was natürlich auch ein Fünchenwahl ist, mache ich ja auch regelmäßig, ich habe mir das ja abtrainiert, die Scham, andere Leute zurechtzuweisen, von oben herab und mache das ja regelmäßig. Aber genau das ist, glaube ich, diese Gegenstimme, die mich immer schon nervt, nämlich die des extrovertierten Menschens, weil viele gesellschaftliche Gepflogenheiten, die gerade existieren
und gang und gäbe sind, basieren
halt darauf, dass man
extrovertiert ist. Und das ist ja
nicht so. Und man könnte
sogar vielleicht annehmen, dass es in den letzten Jahren
sogar so geworden ist, dass
es immer weniger extrovertierte Menschen gibt
durch Internet und jeder ist bei sich
und zieht sich ein bisschen eine
Bubble zurück, weil es einfach angenehmer ist.
Und das finde ich so schade, dass diese Leute
ausser Acht lassen, weil es einfach angenehmer ist.
Und das finde ich so schade, dass diese Leute auch zu Acht lassen, dass es einfach auch unangenehm ist und das Ganze ja noch potenziert zu einem schlechteren Bahnaufenthalt, wenn man die ganze Zeit mit sich kämpft und nicht derjenige sein will. Ja, das ist ja fast noch schlimmer, wenn du, also mir wäre es, na, weiss ich nicht, aber wenn du einfach sagen würdest, es gibt keine Ruhebereiche mehr.
So, dann sagst du einfach, okay, überall ist laut und dann musst du dich aber auch nicht ärgern. Weil fast ist ja mein eigenes Ärgern eher das, was mich stört, als tatsächlich lautstrahlen. Wie kann man denn, warum setzt man sich genau dahin, warum sind die nicht leise, was so. Und wenn du dann einfach sagst, okay, gibt es nicht mehr, ist ja kein Problem, aber die Regel zu schaffen, aber dann nicht durchzusetzen, ist halt komisch. Weil jetzt muss ich überlegen, war der jetzt wirklich so laut, soll ich da hingehen, das ist eine gestresste Familie, ich sag dem ja auch nie, bitte setzen Sie sich mit Ihren Kindern weg, ich sag immer nur beim nächsten Mal, fürs nächste Mal nur kleiner Hinweis, dass sie, ich weiß, ich weiß, aber ich will möglichst wenig übergriffig sein, sondern einfach, manchmal warte ich auch, bis die Leute aussteigen und sagen, Entschuldigung, vielleicht setzen sich das nächste Mal einfach nicht in den Ruhebereich, wenn sie wissen, dass ihre Kinder laut sind. Da hinten gab es, und manchmal gucke ich extra noch nach, ob Platz ist woanders, in anderen Abteilen im Familienbereich. Das war doch schlimmer. Es gab noch Platz, gucken Sie einfach, man kann das von außen sehen. Aber was ist denn deine Reaktion? Weil ich denke mir, das ist ja fast noch schlimmer als kurz so ein Pizis Ruheabteil, weil so nach vier Stunden Bahnfahrt offensichtlich die ganze Zeit auf dem Kicker dieses jungen Mannes gewesen zu sein, der sogar extra in andere Waggons gegangen ist. Aber ich bin denen ja egal, wenn du da Eltern bist mit nervigen Kindern, die ja selber versuchen, dass sie leise sind und es klappt immer nicht. Ist ja in Ordnung, dann sage ich, ich will die gar nicht nerven.
Aber was sind denn deine Reaktionen darauf? Was sind die Reaktionen der Menschen darauf, wenn du dann nach fünf Stunden zu dir hingehst und sagst, nächstes Mal bitte anders.
Und das ist etwas, was mich bestärkt in meinem Weg.
Die Leute sagen, aller, aller meistens sagen,
ich wusste gar nicht, dass ich im Ruhr abdecke.
Und dann sage ich mir, okay, da ist doch das Problem
sehr, sehr leicht zu klären.
Entweder darauf hinweisen oder natürlich.
Und wie gesagt, auch mal hier an die Bahn gerichtet,
ich habe andere Möglichkeiten.
Es gibt auch einen anderen Weg, liebe deutsche Bahn.
Es gibt den leichten Weg oder es gibt den klebrigen Weg.
Und die Ich habe andere Möglichkeiten. Es gibt auch einen anderen Weg, liebe Deutsche Bahn. Es gibt den leichten Weg oder es gibt den klebrigen Weg. Und ihr müsst euch quasi für einen entscheiden. Okay, nochmal. Als dein Anwalt möchte ich das... Es ist keine Drohung in dem Sinne... Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, ich drücke es anders aus. Wir zeigen nur einen Wege auf. Wir lösen dieses Problem mit dem Zeigefinger vor den Lippen oder wir lösen das Problem mit dem Klebeband, liebe deutsche Bahn.
Ja, das kam schon gerade durch. Haben wir uns verstanden soweit? Also drohen Sie mir gerade der Bahn. Nein, es gibt, ich zeige nur ganz objektiv die Wege auf, die es gibt. Ja, kann man nicht auch als Ruheabteil-erin, der die dann Tickets kauft dafür, einfach darauf bestehen? Also hat man nicht ein Recht darauf? Ich will das auch nicht machen, ich will auch nicht snitchen, ich will auch nicht sagen, Entschuldigung, der da hinten ist laut, können Sie dem bitte sagen, das ist ganz furchtbar, will ich nicht.
Aber es ist ein Weg, glaube ich, den wir auch, es ist einfach ein gesellschaftlicher Diskurs, den wir auch einfach mal führen müssen.
Ich glaube, allein durch die Petition wird vielen Leuten über... Aber es ist ein Weg, glaube ich, den wir auch einfach ein gesellschaftlicher Diskurs, den wir auch einfach mal führen müssen.
Ich glaube, allein durch die Petition wird vielen Leuten überhaupt klar, dass es sowas wie einen Ruhebereich überhaupt gibt, dass es Leute gibt, die das stört, wenn sie da laut sind. All das hilft ja schon mal. Ich war jetzt die Tage im Kino, habe den Film The Northman gesehen und habe den Genossen, sofern es ging.
Denn hinter mir sass ein, und dies waren mit Abstand Ältesten im Kino, von daher mal zumindest irgendwie ein bisschen was für den Mix ganz gut. Also da war die Matrix hat sich da mal ein bisschen was ausgedacht, was Innovatives, denn die Störer waren in dem Fall einfach ein altes Ehepaar oder was auch immer. So und dann sassen wir hinter, macht es für mich aber das schwieriger irgendwie. Absolut. Kenne ich auch gut aus dem Ruheabteil. In meiner Erfahrung, Rentnern ist alles scheißegal. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch eine Phase des Lebens, auf die ich mich ein bisschen freue. Einfach zu sagen, mir tut mein ganzer Körper weh, ich kann mich kaum bewegen. Ich schaue nicht mehr zurück, wenn ich einen Rückkehrsgang einlege. Genau. Aber dafür ist mir alles egal. Mir ist mir alles egal. Das finde ich einfach grossartig. Außer ich muss halt meine Pillen um 12 Uhr einnehmen. Ja genau. Aber auf dem Weg zu diesen Pillen boxe ich jeden aus dem Weg, jeder wird angemault, ich stehe im Weg, ich stehe falsch, ich bin Einbahnstrasse, fahre ich falsch rum rein. Um 9 Uhr Uhr habe ich schon drei Piccolo drin, ist mir das alles scheißegal. Schön mit einem Eierlikörchen am Steuer, ich fahre auf der linken Spur. Und auf der Nase diesen kleinen Deckel, immer so ein Deckel von so einem kurzen auf der Nase. Mir ist alle, ich baller einfach, ich walze alles nieder. Ja, und die haben in diesem, genau in dieser Linie haben die dann auch geredet. Ja.
Und ich habe mich immer wieder umgeguckt, was ich ja gerne mache, dieses Umgucken, weil es ist, alle Köpfe gucken nach vorne und wenn hinter jemand sitzt und du guckst dich um, ist alle, die gucken sofort auf dich, weil was tut sich im Kinosaal. Haben aber weiter gesprochen. Aber dann kam es zu dieser blöden Situation, dass mein Kumpel plötzlich, weil ihn der Film irgendwann auch, glaube ich, verloren hat, auch angefangen hat, mit mir zu reden. Nein! Und ich immer so gesagt habe, ja, ja. Ich kann das jetzt politisch gerade gar nicht brauchen. Und es hat meine ganze, mein Hochstart ist komplett zerstört, weil auch er angefangen hat zu sprechen. Und ich war kurz davor, bei dem Paarchen in den Interview zu sagen, das geht nicht mehr. In dem Moment, aber er hat einmal, und es ist ja auch die Frage, was einen ja nicht so doll stört, ist dieses leise miteinander. Das Kino war jetzt auch nicht komplett voll, es war The Northman. Nicht The Southman. Es war nicht The Southman, okay, die viel beliebtere Reine. Entspannt euch. Also jetzt entspannte ich, es war relativ leer. Und deswegen, wenn dann so Inseln sind aus Leuten, und man redet mal so mit seiner Begleitung, das hört man nicht, das ist unmöglich zu hören.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich bin auch eher Hardliner.
Aber hinter mir war schon einfach in diesem Ton gesprochen.
Und dann ging die Musik laut und dann gingen die Action-Szenen hoch, wie gesagt, The Northman, kamen dann auch Action-Szenen natürlich, die ein oder andere, dann wurde auch lauter gesprochen, weil der Film ist ja gerade zu laut, würdest du mich ja nicht verstehen. Und man denkt so, das kann ja ja ernst sein. Und irgendwann hat mein Kummel ab und zu mal was gesagt, immer diesen Flüsterton, fand ich entspannt, aber dann irgendwann auch einfach so, ja. Und dann dachte ich mir, das geht jetzt nicht mehr. Nee, das geht nicht. Aber politisch war das wirklich einfach.
Ja, du kannst das gerade nicht brauchen.
Es war wie eine Zange in die Speichen.
Ich bin umgekippt.
Es war furchtbar.
Aber Rentner sind echt das Beste.
Ich war im Kino und dann labern die natürlich die ganze Zeit.
Und dann dachte ich mir schon, okay, ist das furchtbar, ist das schrecklich.
Soll ich gehen, soll ich was sagen?
Und dann holen die wirklich aus ihrer Tasche eine schöne Packung Pralines raus und dann schön aus diesem Knisterplastik einzeln raus und dann schön mit so einem leergesaugt, weil da anscheinend irgendwie Alkohol drin war oder was, schön jede einzelne Prallinie. Ich sitze in einem Sketch. Die Piedmont-Piereschen. Es kann nicht sein, dass jetzt das lautestmögliche noch gegessen wird und einfach nur und dann holen die noch so ein Airhorn raus und dann einfach aus ihrer Tat so eine Trommel. Also absolut absurd. Das lautestmögliche Essen, was man überhaupt essen kann, Wo man wirklich auch eigentlich sich nicht mehr beschweren kann, weil die Beschwerde würde aus dem Ausland haben. Haben sie eigentlich gar nichts verstanden bestehen? Man kann ab einem Wutlevel nicht mehr, man kann einfach nur sagen, ich fliehe einfach, ich fliehe. Aber du kannst ja nicht sagen, können sie mit der Reise sein, weil dann stellen sie halt nur eine Sache ein dann stellen sie sich vielleicht das Reden ein oder sowas, aber du musst ja quasi, du musst ja einmal mit dem Rundumschlag kommen.
Man muss ja ganz von vorne anfangen.
Man muss ja sagen, worüber wollen wir als erstes reden?
Über ihr konstantes Geschnatter, über ihre Essenssachen, darüber, dass sie viel zu spät kamen,
darüber, dass sie ewig nicht den Platz gefunden haben, dafür, dass sie ständig Fragen stellen.
Worüber wollen wir als erstes reden? Dafür, dass sie telefoniert haben.
Übrigens an der Stelle liebe Grüße an Agnes. Bad Carmen, darüber, dass sie ewig nicht den Platz gefunden haben, dafür, dass sie ständig Fragen stellen.
Worüber wollen wir als erstes?
Dafür, dass sie telefoniert haben, übrigens an der Stelle liebe Grüße an Agnes.
An Agnes und den lieben
Benni, der sich am Wochenende um die Katze kümmert,
freut mich. Auch das klang übrigens so,
als ob sie da das und das machen können.
Ja, noch so Lebenstipps geben.
Ja, genau. Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist schrecklich, aber naja.
Deswegen, es ist aber auch wichtig, ich dachte in dem Moment, du brauchst auch den Status, du musst dich davor so verhalten, wie du predigst. Sonst konnte ich nicht mehr in der Position, dann was sagen zu können. Und dann muss man sich nicht reinfressen, das war ein bisschen doof. Ja, deswegen, falls ihr was Gutes tun wollt, und das ist auch mal jetzt vielleicht ein Friedensangebot an die Extrovertierten da draußen, selbst wenn ihr immer denkt, ich habe da eigentlich kein Problem damit, wenn Leute reden, ich finde das gar nicht so schlimm, ihr könnt ja für andere Leute mal was tun und sagen, ah, okay, es gibt anscheinend Leute, die das stören, dann helfe ich denen mal hier den Ruhebereich durchzusetzen und dann schau mal, wie weit es geht und ich bin bereit, mit Leuten von der Deutschen Bahn zu reden, mich würde auch gerne interessieren, was da das Problem ist, oft als Außenstehender denkt man nämlich, warum machen die das denn nicht, was ist denn das Problem? Vielleicht gibt es handfeste Gründe. Ja, muss ich aber jetzt auch nicht so blöd stellen, ne? Ne, vielleicht, lass uns einfach darüber reden, falls die ein Gegenargument haben und sagen, das ist rechtlich ein Problem, man darf Leuten das nicht untersagen oder was auch immer, keine Ahnung. Oder wir würden damit zu viele Leute verstrecken, die dann nicht mehr Bahn fahren wollen oder was auch immer. Gerne, ich bin zu jedem Gespräch bereit, können wir alles gerne machen.
Aber wie gesagt, wir können das auf zwei Möglichkeiten lösen.
Wir können es mit Worten lösen, wir können es aber auch mit Fäusten lösen, um das mal so ganz deutlich zu sagen.
Nein, ich muss es weniger deutlich sagen.
Gut, dann sage ich es anders.
Wir können das lösen mit der Brieftaube, wir können es aber auch lösen mit dem Habicht. Liebe Bahn. Okay, das war undeutlich genug, ja. War das undeutlich genug? Abgenickt. Alles klar. Dann haben wir uns verstanden, glaube ich. Ja, okay, wie gesagt, wir sind eine Passive Aggressiveness. Brieftaube oder Bluthund, Deutsche Bahn? Bluthund ist so, nee, das darf nichts. Gut.
Brieftaube oder Aal, ja? Sperrbär. Brieftaube oder Elektro-Aal, liebe Bahn. Entscheidet euch für eins. Ja, okay. Okay? Finde ich gut. Gut, dann haben wir es jetzt auch. Eine andere Storyline, die, obwohl ich auch dachte, wäre schon auserzählt, ging weiter. Und zwar habe ich aus erster Hand erfahren, dass in Köln am Bahnhof die Brezeln wieder 2,40 Euro kostet. Nein, wirklich? Drei Stück. Wir erinnern uns alle an meinen Klasse-Mitschnitt, Privatdetektiv Sherlock Stephan, massiv illegal, 2,60 Euro gezahlt für zwei.. Jetzt wieder für drei Stück 2,40 Euro. Weißt du, wann das vielleicht liegt? Ich war jetzt ein paar Wochen nicht da. Ich war jetzt ein paar Wochen bei einer anderen Bäckerei, wo ich erstmal statt inwärts gehen musste, einen ziemlich grossen Umweg gehen musste für billigere Brezeln, um dann zum Bahnhof zu gehen. Vielleicht lag das daran. Ich glaube nämlich auch. Das ist mein Jahr. Das wird mein Jahr. die Petition wird gross, die Brezeln werden billig, Slush-Eis kommt zurück. Ich glaube, das ist mein Ja. Ja, meine Theorie war nämlich auch, dass du die Preise künstlich in die Höhe treibst, durch deinen massiven Laugenbrezelkonsum. Und zwar gibt es ja, was ich immer noch fantastisch finde, es gab in Berlin lange die Bierbörse. Ein fantastisches System, wo ich nicht verstehe, warum es das nicht für sämtliche andere Lokalitäten gibt. Und zwar war die Idee, die haben sämtliche Biersorten da und eine grosse Börsenanzeige. Und je nachdem, was an dem Abend bestellt wird, regelt Angebot und Nachfrage den Preis. Okay. Das heißt, wir waren damals mit unserer Schule da, mit unserem Sovi-Kurs und haben dann da irgendeine Lehre eine Runde Jermeister oder sowas ausgegeben und dann siehst du wirklich, wie der Preis für Jägermeister dann für alle in der Bar gerade steigt, weil halt alle das gerade kaufen und du sozusagen den Aktienkurs in die Höhe treibst. Das heißt, du wirst motiviert, das zu kaufen, was niemand kauft und entdeckst neue Sachen. Genau, entdeckst neue Sachen und ich finde das fantastisch. Und so ist es aber ein bisschen auch mit dir, weil du treibst ja, weil du halt so regelmäßig zwei Laugenbrezel kaufst. Die Brezeln und immer wenn die Brezeln teurer werden, werden die Nussecken billiger. Oder Franzböhrchen, ja, man kann auch einmal mal zum Franzböhrchen greifen. Der Gesamtpreis aller Produkte bleibt immer gleich, nur wenn eins erhöht wird, geht es irgendwo anders wieder runter. Das stimmt, das ist eigentlich eine gute, ja, das ist interessant, kann man gut zu verdeutlichen. Und das gibt es nirgendwo anders, gibt es auch glaube ich da nicht mehr. Ich frage mich, ob das vielleicht finanziell spielt oder ob man irgendwann, das wird, immer schlechtere Getränke zu trinken. Ja, vielleicht funktioniert das System am Ende doch nicht, wenn der so wie Kurs rausgeht und sagt, das ist eigentlich ein Scheissystem. Können wir das nicht anders machen und der Lehrer, was, was, nein, das ist doch okay, ja, aber warum, dann müssen ja die Leute immer die schlechten Sachen kaufen. Man hört nur so, man sieht nur der Wirt dann so, der einfach so sagt. So, dann gehen wir jetzt noch in den Tierpark. Und der Wirt überhört dann nur diesen Lobby-Kurs, der entscheidet, dass ein schlechter System ist, und dreht einfach nur dieses Schild um, für immer geschlossen. Und schmeißt den Lappen in die Ecke. Mit dem klassischen, mit der Wirtbewegung eigentlich. Ich bin hier fertig. Fertig oder ich poliere gerade ein Glas. Die zwei Sachen. Ich will einmal nur einen Abend als Barkeeper arbeiten, um diese Einlernphase zu haben. Ja, also im Grunde gibt es zwei Bewegungen. Einmal das Glas polieren und einmal das näher zum Kunden ranlehnen und trotzdem nicht verstehen, was er soll. Ja, genau. Was? Kriegst du Cola am Ende. Ich habe den neuen Uncharted-Film gesehen, ganz, ganz schrecklicher Film, aber es gibt diese sehr lustige Szene, weil die Debrotten hatten sich irgendwie überlegt, wie machen wir Tom Holland am Anfang zum coolen Guy, coolen Barkeeper. Und es bestellt jemand Negroni bei ihm. Negroni, für dich, einfachster Drink der Welt sind drei Zutaten, die man zum gleichen Teil zusammen mischt. Und dann gibt es so einen Fünf-Minuten-Dialog, dass er die besten Negronis macht. Und sowas hast du noch nie gesehen. Und ich habe, keine Ahnung, spezielle Zutaten und sowas, aber er macht die drei rein, aber es ist so eine Fünfteminutenssene und seitdem muss ich immer darüber lachen, weil Barkeeper, ich meine, es ist schon ein machbarer Job, wenn man die Rezepte gut kennt, klar. Also gibt es schwierige Sachen wahrscheinlich und nicht so schwierige Sachen, aber bei so einfachen Longdrinks, einfach gestreckt drei Zutaten beieinander. Ich habe mich gefragt, ich kann noch so viele Drinks nehmen, die wahrscheinlich schwieriger, ich kenne mich auch nicht aus, zu produzieren sind, aber es war in diesem Film so lange Thema, dass er die besten macht und dass man das noch nie so gut getrunken hat wie sein Mikroni. Aber es sind drei Zutaten. Es ist schon merkwürdig, weil das auch die Qualität nur an dem Mischverhältnis besteht. Ich verstehe, wenn jemand eine gute Spaghetti Bolognese macht, wenn man richtig kochen kann und dann kann man Sachen falsch machen. Aber es geht ja bei Drinks nur darum zu mischen. Genau, du veränderst keine Aggregatzustände, es geht nicht um Hitze, du musst auch nichts aufschlagen, du brauchst keine guten Zutaten. Es sind drei Zutaten, die du immer gleich kaufst. Die kriegst du neben Lidl, Netto, Aldi, überall kriegst du diese drei Zutaten. Das schmeckt immer gleich. Und warum nimmt die sich dann diesen Drink raus? Und ich dachte die ganze Zeit, das wäre ein Scherz und es wird irgendwann aufgelöst. Aber nein, es ging einfach darum, dass er die besten Negronis in der fucking Stadt macht. Er macht den besten Kiba der ganzen Stadt. Aber ist es bei Bakibern auch so, ich kenne diese Legende von Supersterneköchen, dass wenn man bei so einem Supersternerestaurant anfangen will, das erste, was man kochen muss, ist ein Spiegelei. Oder sowas ganz simples, wo man immer denkt, hä, was? Aber ein richtig guter Koch kann auch ein Spiegelei richtig gut machen. Ist das bei Barcaebern auch so, dass das erste, was du machst, ist Mineralwasser, dass du erst mal sagst, jetzt zeig mir erst mal dein Mineralwasser. Okay, dann würde ich erst mal, okay, hast klar, würde ein schönes Glas nehmen, dass ich vorher die Bewegung machen, dass man sauber macht, schön. Okay, er hat einen schönen Rhythmus bei seiner Drehbewegung, okay, auch nur rechts rum. Ich würde ein schickes Glas nehmen, jetzt nicht irgendwie das Ikea-Glas. Machen Sie das, wie Sie meinen, wie Sie meinen. Ja, ich erkläre es nur, weil es ist schwierig für Leute, das zu verstehen. Machen Sie einfach, Sie müssen dabei gar nicht reden. Ich glaube nicht, dass das so spannend ist. So, dann würde ich drei... Machen Sie es ruhig, wie gesagt, der Kunde muss das Geheimnis gar nicht verstehen. Drei Eiswürfel würde ich reinmachen. So, hier mit dieser Zange, mit dieser kleinen Eiswürfelzange. Dann würde ich ein Stück... Oh, erst die Eiswürfel, dann das, okay. Was schreiben Sie sich da auf? Nichts. Dann würde ich hier diese kleine Zitronenscheibe nehmen. Nicht die Limette? Nö. Ganz bewusst so, dann nehme ich hier noch ein Stück Minzblatt. Ein Blatt, ja. Und jetzt kommt das gute Mineralwasser drauf. Okay, Glas nicht angewinkelt. Das habe ich nur nicht gesagt. Gereingemacht? So, bitteschön, das Mineralwasser her. Okay, dann Prost. Prösterchen. Mein Gott, das ist das beste Mineralwasser, das ich hier getrunken habe. Sie sind eingestellt. Das ist das beste im ganzen Land, wo dieses Mineralwasser bekannt wird. So ein bisschen war die Szene, ehrlich gesagt. Nur, dass wir von drei Tutaten sprechen. Aber müsste man auch einfach mal eine Legende aufbauen. Alter, in der Bar, da gibt es das beste Mineralwasser der ganzen Stadt. Und ich glaube, die Leute gehen anders dahin. Und vielleicht ist es dann wirklich besser mit der Erwartungshaltung. Aber ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel man da falsch machen kann. Ich fühle mich immer schlecht, wenn ich in der Bar gehe und Mineralwasser bestelle. Wo ich mir so denke, das ist so, als würde man Luft bestellen. Das ist so, ja, wir haben hier alles, alle Drinks aus der ganzen Welt und du bestellst irgendwie Leitungswasser. Oh, was wir in Deutschland übrigens mal durchsetzen müssen, kriege ich von ausländischen Menschen gespiegelt. Es gibt hier nicht diese Kranwasser. Kostenloses Wasser, ja. Kostenloses Wasser zu allem dazu Mentalität, die es zum Beispiel in den USA gibt oder auch irgendwie in der Schweiz, Österreich und so, kriegt man häufiger mal einfach Tafelwasser. Das gibt es hier nicht. Zudem kauft man immer für sehr viel Geld einfach stilles Wasser oder so zum Tisch mit grossen Flaschen und so. Und dann kann man da so diese grossen Wasserflaschen am Tisch stehen. Das braucht man, das muss ja nicht sein. Also deswegen dieses leicht nach Chlor schmeckende Kranwasser, was in so einem grossen offenen Bottich, wo alle hustende Menschen dran vorbeilaufen, auf dem Tisch steht, mit Eiswüreln drin, wo jeder mal reinhusten darf, wo ganz viele Eishüffel drin sind, die langsam schmelzen und dann werden so Partikel, die in diesem unsauberen Eis eingefroren sind, werden das Wasser auch zum Wasser. Das will man ja am Tisch haben für alle. Kostenloses Wasser dazu. Das ist meine Petition. Okay, mach gerne Petitionen auf. Ich bin mir, du heisst einfach 10.000. Sofort rein, Neckarpresse springt auf den Zug auf. Aber es ist natürlich, der wird natürlich den guten deutschen Gastronomen wahrscheinlich viel Geld durch die Hände fließen. Wenn du das sagst, dann sagen die, unser Umsatz schmilzt wie Eiswürfel. Oder wie so ein Sorbet, nee, Soufflé. Ist dir aufgefallen? Warum lachst du immer nur durch die Nase? Ist dir aufgefallen, wie windig es gerade ist draußen übrigens? Ja! Nee, aber kann man da mal kurz, da hat mich noch niemand drüber erzählen, im grossen Manege drüber sprechen hören, dass es so doll windet gerade.
Und ich musste richtig lachen, weil
dann im Film The Northman
war die ganze Zeit auch windig.
Und ich dachte, okay, ist jetzt so. Das ist die neue Realität.
Jetzt hat irgendwer beschlossen, es ist überall
und immer, selbst in der Fiktion,
es war immer windig. Alle hatten immer alle Bärte,
jedes Haar.
Ich dachte immer so, gib den Haaren doch mal jetzt ein bisschen
Ruhe. Aber jedes Barthaar,
jedes Kopfhaar, alles war
die ganze Zeit im Wind, die ganze Zeit
Aber Ich hatte jedes Haar, ich dachte immer so, gib den Haaren doch mal jetzt ein bisschen Ruhe, aber jedes Barthaar, jedes Kopfhaar, alles war die ganze Zeit im Wind, die ganze Zeit, der Ton war die ganze Zeit. Also wie will man so? So war der Ton, again, nicht the Southman, ich war in the North. Wir haben es verstanden, nicht den sehr relaxten, windstillen Strand Southman. Warmen, sehr warmen, eher in sehr rangstönen, rot rot Tönen gehaltenen. Schön prickelnder Sangria am Strand. Wo nicht viel passiert. Fast wenig. Ja. Ab und zu, wollt ihr Beachball spielen? Na, später vielleicht. Ja, später vielleicht. Später vielleicht. Das ist ein anderer Film als der Northman. Aber wir sind nicht der Northman. Das ist ja auch schön, es ist leib. Es gibt aber in jedem Film ein paar, die enttäuscht sind, weil sie dachten, sie sitzen im anderen Film. Das ist immer das Problem. So ein paar Northman-Fans, so richtige Wikinger mit so geflochtenen Bärten dann bei Southman. Ja, aber Southman ist so, du hast immer so ein bisschen Raggaeton-Musik. Und österreichische Leute am Strand sitzen und dann Cut zu Northman. Wir flippen alle mal ab! Oh die Welt! Ja, so das ist ein bisschen der Unterschied Unterschied, aber auch da, windig, windig, windig. Und ich habe irgendwie, ich höre auch, glaube ich, so einen Fokus gerade darauf, also selektive Wahrnehmung. Ich gehe durch die Welt und denke mir, es ist sau windig gerade. Ich trage das seit ein paar Wochen mit mir rum, dieses Gefühl. Das ist ein guter Punkt. Alle denken bei Klimawandel immer nur an, ja, Wärme, ja, aber dadurch gibt es ja noch ganz andere viele Wetterphänomene.
Wahrscheinlich ist auch, vielleicht wäre das ein viel besserer Talking Point, als zu sagen, es wird warm, wo die meisten Leute sagen, cool, kannst du vielleicht sagen, nein, lass uns mal, vielleicht wenn Fridays for Future mithört, geht mal komplett weg von dem Wärmeding, sondern geht einfach hin zu Windstärke. Jedes Jahr fünf kmh. Jeder hasst Wind, jeder liebt Wärme.
Das wäre doch mal einfach so ein Poster.
Jedes Jahr fünf kmh. Jeder hasst Wind, jeder liebt Wärme. Das wäre doch mal einfach so ein Poster.
Jedes Jahr fünf
kmh schneller. Wie schnell
soll es sein? Fragezeichen. Wie viel
Wind wollt ihr noch? Ja, aber es ist schön,
weil man betont gerade die guten, also ein bisschen
die guten Sachen. Es wird wärmer
und sonniger. Also es ist halt nicht das
und die Meeresspiegel steigen.
Ja, auf eine Art will man ja. Das heißt, ihr habt
mehr zum Baden und es ist wärmer. Ja, ihr habt mehr Strände, Nähe an uns dran, mit mehr Wärme. Holland geht unter. Und wann kommen die negativen Sachen? Ja, genau. So, und da ist einfach, wenn du sagst, einfach jedes Jahr 10 kmh all in und die tauchen alle mit Föns auf und alles. Das ist vielleicht mal ein Talking Point, weil Wind ist nicht angenehm. Ja, und auch die tollen Vokabeln, die dann da kommen mit diesem Assoziationsgebiet.
Orkane. Ja. Niemand mag diese Sachen. Orkan, Tornado, Vulkane. Windhose. Windhose. Windhose. Wirbelwind. Brise. Das kommt alles nochmal um die Ecke. Dann entsprechen wir auch alle so eher Nordischer, weil wir alle so dann die Brise und dann alles so auch dieses Vokabular dann sich weiter ergibt. Und dann kann es sein, dass wir alle weggeblasen werden. Aber natürlich auch gut für Windkraft. Ja, gut. Das stimmt natürlich. Also schiesst sich der Klimawandel nicht selber ins Bein. Je mehr Wind, desto mehr Windkraft, desto weniger Klimawandel. Er zärt am eigenen Ast.
Moment, von welcher Organisation
seid ihr jetzt?
Nee, nee, wir sind die Außenstehenden.
Ihr müsst euch vorstellen, wir sind diese Kommentatoren,
die einfach das Ganze
wie so ein Sportereignis kommentieren.
Und uns ist gerade nur aufgefallen, dass wir
keine Meinung, also wir finden den Klimawandel doof,
aber uns ist eher aufgefallen, dass wir gerade eher, dass sich das vielleicht von alleine lösen das Problem. Okay. Bei näherem Hinschauen. Aber again, ohne wirklich viel Wissen. Geh da mal mit auf so eine Demo mit so einem grossen Plakat, der Klimawandel schießt sich selbst ins Bein. Schießt sich selbst ins Bein. Und einfach so, weil ich mag ja eh dieses Genre-Demo-Plakate, finde ich ja eh grandios, weil du komplexe Sachverhalte eindampfen musst auf klare Formeln.
Und manchmal kommen dadurch sehr verwirrende Sachen dadurch.
Deine Bastelfähigkeiten spielen auch einen nicht unwesentlichen Anteil, weil nicht nur musst du deine grossen Meinungen, deine politischen Meinungen auf dieses kleine Pakat bekommen, sondern auch die Variable wie sehr kannst du das und wie sehr scheitert du schon zum Beispiel an Happy Birthday Karten, weil du in der Mitte mit Happy anfängst und dann für das Y keinen Platz mehr hast und bei Birthday wieder den gleichen Fehler machst. Das bringst du ja auch mit. Und ich war hier in Köln auf einer Demo und habe dann tatsächlich sehr, sehr viele Plakate gesehen, die das auch hatten, das Problem. Also wo Frieden und das N war sehr schmal. Es war fast nie. Man unterschätzt M und N immer. Unterschätzt man das N? Plan für M und N mal doppelt einen Bereich ein wie für normalen Buchstaben. Und dann ist es vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel. Okay, okay, wir kommen damit klar.
Aber es ist dann nicht, es sah aus wie Frieden, Friedi, Friedi.
Was wollt ihr?
Aber manchmal ist es auch schwer, das klar darzustellen. Ich habe zum Beispiel mal ein fantastisches T-Shirt gesehen, nicht inhaltlich, aber einfach
logisch, und zwar stand auf dem T-Shirt Cancel, Cancel Culture.
Das erste Cancel war aber durchgestrichen. Und es ist so, also erst mal der Spruch Cancel, Cancel Culture, okay, gut, Alliteration, ergibt Sinn, aber das erste Cancel war durchgestrichen. Also die sind dagegen, die Cancel Culture zu canceln, also sind sie dafür? Also es ist ganz, ganz mehr... Also erstmal, wenn es nicht durchgestrichen wäre... Ja, das würde total Sinn ergeben. Gegen Cancel Culture. Genau. Wir canceln Cancel Culture. Jetzt, wo das erste durchgestrichen ist... Richtig. Wir sind dagegen, Cancel Culture zu canceln. Waren aber mal dafür. Das ist, glaube ich, das ist mein Takeaway. Ja, es erzählt eine Geschichte. Ja, es erzählt den eigenen politischen Werdegang mit diesem Thema. Man war mal gegen Cancel Culture, inzwischen hat man sich aber unentschieden und hat das auch noch veranschaulichen wollen. Aber ich hätte gerne noch ein T-Shirt gemacht, wo dieses gesamte T-Shirt nochmal durchgestrichen wird. Also du hast so dieses Durchgestrichen und darin ist dieser Aufdruck, das Cancel, Cancel Culture, erste Cancel durchgestrichen und das ist noch mal komplett durchgestrichen. Also wenn man das T-Shirt sieht, erst mal wirklich sich eine Minute nehmen muss und sagt, wie viele Verneinungen haben wir gerade, wo sind wir gerade, bin ich dafür oder nicht oder will ich das auch wieder durchstreichen? Das ist einfach, das war ganz gut. Ich Ich hab auch ein T-Shirt gesehen, da wurde es warm.
Jetzt kommen wieder die Gag-T-Shirts raus.
Die Dads mit den Gag-T-Shirts.
Macht euch gefasst.
Suns out, Gags out!
Ich hab den Shirt gesehen, da war ...
Und das war ...
Das muss man sich auch erst mal vorstellen.
Es war ein ...
Man kennt das EKG-Takt.
Ja.
Genau, diese Wellenformen.
Und zwar sechsmal.
Sechsmal gab es Erhebungen,
das ist noch wichtig für die Story.
Und dann über jedem Berg Erhebung standen
Zahlen, die Zahlen eins bis sechs.
Die eins und dann
auch die ganze Welle, der Ausschlag
war grün. Ganz rechts
die sechs, sechs an sich und
der Ausschlag unten drunter war rot. Und unten drunter stand, das verstehst du jetzt nicht. Und ich habe da gesessen, ich war kurz davor, diese Familie anzusprechen am Nebentisch, um mir das zu erklären. Aber ist das der Gag, dass man es einfach nicht versteht, oder? Ich habe es nicht verstanden. So, das verstehst du nicht. Dann habe ich es gegoogelt. Das verstehst du nicht, Shirt. Und ich habe es inzwischen gelöst. Und zwar scheint es ein Motorrad-Fan zu sein, der gern seinen Sechstakter fährt. Und das war so blöd antiklimatisch. Warum ist der erste grün und der sechste rot? Ja, genau. Es war so doof und es war so antiklimatisch. Und ich fand das so blöd, dass, ah, okay, das Gefühl eines Sechstaktors, das verstehe ich nicht und so. Aber das ist ja schon so viel vorausgesetzt. Ich war noch nicht auf dem Motorrad. Also das ist ja so ein blödes, nischiges Kackschirr. Vor allem, natürlich verstehst du es nicht. Ich kann auch mein Hobby abbilden und sagen, das verstehst du nicht.
Ja, aber es ist ja nicht nur dein Hobby abgebildet, es ist ja sogar eine Unterform deines Hobbys, die du nämlich sechstakt erfährst. Das will ich mir. Genau, das verstehst du jetzt nicht. Das ist vor allem die Eins geht nach unten, während die anderen fünf nach oben gehen. Und zwischen Eins und Zwei ist ein grünes N abgebildet. Übrigens, und zwar bist du gerade auf einer
bekannten Website, und es gibt viele von
diesen Websiten, wo du
Shirts kaufen kannst, die jemand anderer designt hat.
Und immer siehst du die gleichen Models da stehen.
Das heißt, irgendein Model hat
mal diesen Vertrag unterschrieben,
jedes Shirt der Welt,
hier klar, darfst du auf meinen Körper
setzen. Das heißt, die sind ja mit Gesicht
und so voll drin. Und es gibt so ein paar, drei Models oder sowas, Also ich kenne jetzt auch von den Männern die Shirts, weil das sind die, wo ich nachher suche. Aber drei Male Models haben gesagt, ja, klar könnt ihr, jedes Shirt der Welt bedrucken mit was auch immer und macht noch drei Hakenkreuze drauf. Und dann zieht es mir an, zieht mir alle Shirts an. Wie viel Urvertrauen oder so, was haben die dafür bekommen? Gute Frage. Seid ihr das? Oder konnten die im Vertrag, der war so eine freie Stelle im Vertrag, hier dürft ihr reinschreiben, was ihr nicht auf euch haben wollt. Okay, Sechstakter Motor. Sechstakter Motor, Hakenkreuz, Schwer jetzt aus dem Stehgreif alles zu benennen. Ente? Ich mag Enten nicht so gern. Das ist schwierig, weil Enten basierte Shirts. Oder dass man immer so, wenn man so dieses T-Shirt gestaltet, die Anzahl der Models immer kleiner wird. Und je mehr man hinzufügt, desto kleiner wird die Anzahl. Und irgendwann nur noch Roy, der einfach gesagt hat, wisst ihr, mir ist alles völlig egal. Genau, Roy hat da diese Zeile freigelassen. Roy, ey. Alles für Roy. Fucking Roy. Roy ist einfach unter den Models auch einfach verschrien. Der hat seine Seele verkauft. Er hat seine Seele verkauft, deswegen das beste Model. Ja. Oder unanspruchsvoll. Naja. Würdest du als Model Erfolg haben, meinst du? Kannst du gut posieren? Nein. Ich kann auch nicht, auch Fotos kann ich nicht gucken. Ich mache mir die Augen zu, ich habe gar kein Gefühl für mein Gesicht. Fotos, das ist schrecklich. Ich bin so massiv unphotogen. Soweit ich weiß, dass eine Kamera auf mich gerichtet ist, verlerne ich das Sein. Deswegen bin ich auch nicht so gerne vor der Kamera, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Auch so bei Rocket Beans und so fand ich immer sehr schwierig. Ich vor der Kamera immer, sobald eine Kamera und es ist nicht mal dieses der physische Gegenstand, es ist das Bewusstsein, dass die an ist und so, lässt mich komplett vergessen, wie man spricht und aussieht. Und wie oft macht man seine Augenbrauen hoch oder so? Das sind alles so Fragen, die man sich dann stellt. Wie oft blinzelt man? Habe ich jetzt gerade schon geblinzelt? Darf ich schon wieder blinzeln? Die Fragen, die man sich stellt. Ich habe jetzt seit drei Sekunden nicht geblinzelt. Ist es jetzt wieder in Ordnung zu blinzeln? Man guckt in die Runde und die blinzeln auch ab und ab. Die blinzeln auch? Die blinzeln schon auch. Ja, ja, ja. Viel zu viel. Ja, dann hat man was wagen sollen in der Zwischenzeit. Ich habe viel zu viel blinzeln. Du blinzelst häufig, ist mir auch aufgefallen. Ich blinze sehr häufig, ja, auch wenn ich so Aufnahmen von mir sehe, denke ich, Alter, was ist denn dein Problem gerade? Und ist ein Zeichen von, und das habe ich, weiss ich, durch die Behind the Scenes von Das Schweigen der Lämmer, da hat sich ja Er hat sich die Hauptkennzeiten nie geblinzelt. Genau, nie geblinzelt, weil, danke, dass du mir die ganzen Sachen sagst, weil ich noch zehn Minuten nach dem Namen gesucht, hat nicht geblinzelt, um halt Überlegenheit auszudrücken, weil Leute, die nicht blinzeln, gelten als überlegen, weil sie sind Herr über sich und die haben Kontrolle.
Aber der andere versucht, unbewusst den Blickkontakt zu unterdrücken,
weil man sich nicht wohlfühlt.
Nicht wohlfühlt wahrscheinlich auch, aber auch, ich glaube, Kontrolle über den eigenen Körper zu haben und so zeigt auch generell eine Form von Überlegenheit und Kontrolle über die Situation aus und sowas.
Und Clarice Starning hat immer... Ich glaube auch so, Kontrolle über den eigenen Körper zu haben und so, zeigt auch generell eine Form von Überlegenheit und Kontrolle über die Situation aus und sowas.
Und Clarice Starling hat immer geblinzelt natürlich, wenn man das so macht. Und das ist, glaube ich, wenn man es zurück überträgt, wäre das eine Form von Unterlegenheit.
Ich bin definitiv der Jodie Foster-Charakter in jedem Kontext, wo ich auftrete.
Ich bin einfach immer unterlegen, ich bin die junge auszubildende FBI-Agentin, ich bin wissbegierlich. Fly, Clarice, fly. Wie hart das auch nach hinten hätte losgehen können, oder? Dass einfach Anthony Hopkins sagt, ich biete mir was an. With some liver beans. Ja, ich würde sagen, wir machen noch ein Take gerade. Nee, ring, ring, passt bitte auf, zieht keine grossen Kleidungsstücke an, ihr könntet weggeblasen werden. Und das wird natürlich tragisch. Versucht, Segel zu vermeiden. Haltet euch fern von grossen Bäumen, die euch erschlagen können und passt auf, macht mal wirklich eine vorsichtige Woche. Machen wir mal voll, passt auf, hier auf. Macht mal wirklich eine ganz vorsichtige Woche. Ich will, dass keinem von euch was passiert, niemandem. Alle kommen in die nächste Woche. Und dann sehen wir uns wieder. Wir lassen niemand zurück. Wir verlieren niemand. In dieser Woche, Leute, verlieren wir hier niemand. Wir wollen uns alle nächste Woche wiedersehen. Bis dahin haut rein, hab eine schöne Woche und wir heben ab!